the ' 60s is when things really started
to change because the Ford foundation
and the Rockefeller Foundation started
to create women's studies departments
and universities and they put massive
amounts of funding into women's suffrage
propaganda and women's Liberation
propaganda telling women that you know
it's very risky to be married and you
should have your own money and you
should have your own credit because what
if he leaves you or what if he becomes
an abuser suddenly that abuse mode just
flips on one day and he becomes like
this awful man and then you're trapped
right um and you even saw a lot of that
in p pop culture in the 70s with movies
like The Stepford Wives where and there
was a bunch of them there's a whole
series of movies that came out that made
it seem like being a stay-at home wife
and mom was like boring and and
unfulfilling that being a career woman
was exciting and cool and that was what
like the 60s is that when the movies
came out started like the late 60s and
then through the' 70s